[Applause]
to win an NBA championship
you have to win games that you probably
shouldn't win
and this is one of those in terms of you
guys didn't play at the end of the game
the way you probably would have liked
absolutely no we we for sure God bless
tonight
um Miami came back storm back we up 10
in the fourth quarter and you try not to
lose and sometimes trying not to lose
makes you lose you gotta keep playing so
I feel like you know we took our foot
off the gas a little bit and you know
they came and made a run and Dwight made
a hell of a play at the end Jalen you
were this close
you were this close to having your
season in 0.5 seconds Ernie not this
close point three seconds and you've
seen Marcus Rim that out I mean did you
think this thing was over
it's not over till it's over I mean but
as you watched that last play happen
so what was I thinking I thought it was
good for a second I think yeah that was
a hell of a play by Marcus too to get it
off so quickly for sure D White come out
of nowhere man like a flash of lightning
look at you look at you look shocked
yeah right there hey it's not over till
it's over Kenny I'll take it you know
Jayla uh yeah it's like point two point
one yeah I don't understand you said
we're up ten you guys gotta win what the
hell why did y'all why do y'all relax
with y'all I mean because y'all done all
playoffs long and then you got in the
whole O3 by doing that what is it about
y'all well y'all just don't say hey man
let's just kill these dudes and get it
over with I guess we just like doing it
the hard way I guess I'm not sure why we
do it um it seems like when we get in
those moments we get a little bit
apprehensive and we kind of like get a
little bit like we just don't want to be
the one to mess up and it causes you to
be the one to mess up I feel like in
those moments we just gotta grow and in
this next couple games that we got this
next game that we got we got to be
better down all three I would like to
know what the conversations were because
it was one game you guys played here
everybody said you guys that quit I
would like to know what the conversation
was was it we're going to make history
was that the first words or was it we're
going to take one game at a time and get
to a game seven the whole conversation
was done let us get one we feel like you
know we didn't play to up to par in the
first three games but we felt like they
played incredible in the first three
games I think they they role players
came out played tremendous and we didn't
really have an answer
um as soon as we feel like we can get
one we feel like we can get two and now
we got three so let's get ready for game
seven trailing it's almost like this
team had to hit rock bottom before you
started playing the way you can play I
mean
have you been lower this season than you
were after game three of this series no
I don't it don't get too much worse than
being down 3-0 so I feel like now we got
a new confidence we feel like we've been
to Hell and back Ernie yeah and now well
and look at this can you believe that
three-point number for you guys tonight
seven out of 35 season low 20 percent
from three and you depend on the three
ball you have all year and you win the
game we had to we had to change our
identity mid playoffs I mean we've been
living and dying by the three ball kind
of on offense but we had to make a make
a stand and be like defense is going to
win us these games defense got us in
these games defense kept us in these
games and we was able to win tonight
because we kept him at 100 points you
know what I have a question that is a
little bit different coach masula at
times in the media have been getting
really really criticized by a lot of
media around the country now it's time
to give him props what in these last
three games has he done and made the
adjustment and how helped him grow as a
coach instead of on the other side
giving him the let's give him some
flowers right now Joe seemed to stay
calm Joe took all the blame he tried to
down the sword but in reality we was all
in this together and we all had to make
adjustments I had to see the game he
pulled me to the side this is where the
game is going to be played it's not
going to always be you scoring the ball
find a way to make an impact on the game
whether it's rebounding whether it's
your defense your presence
um so Joe's just been in our ear this
whole time his first year but he got a
Poise he got a mentality that keeps us
in games and
um now we back in it we know you have
other media obligations after this and
uh so we have to let you go but the last
thing is is do you believe what you just
saw out there because I don't
do you believe what you just saw out
there I don't but we here
I appreciate you I appreciate you guys
Kevin Brown thank you very much
You Want To Make History You Want To
Make History if you win number four
don't forget that just getting the game
seven on making history exactly I got
you
Jalen Brown Arkansas
[Music]
[Applause]